précision concentration pour dorian en
terminale hôtellerie restauration
la cuisine c'est une histoire de famille
on ne peut pas les cuisiniers samassa
m'a donné envie
bakar de la chine aussi j'ai toujours
connu ça
maintenant c'est devenu une passion pour
moi aussi j'aime bien
faire les cuissons et tout ce qui est
des groupes d'aliments à terme il
faudrait ouvrir son restaurant
gastronomique mais avant il faudra faire
ses preuves
et cela passe par ce concours à paris le
14 octobre prochain il devra préparer un
foie gras un mal gré et un confit cd
concours qui se présentent tous les ans
on le fait pas tous les ans parce que
aussi est-ce qu'on a tous les élèves à
chaque fois qu'ils sont motivés pas
forcément là et de rien ne s'est
présenté sur ce concours là parce qu'il
sentait vraiment à l'aise avec ces
produits là à côté de ces concours il ya
le quotidien il faut faire tourner le
saint louis le restaurant du lycée en
salle solène supervise l'installation 35
couverts aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
leur dire allez on a terminé sa vous
vérifier que tout n'a pas dit les
bienfaits on commence par ça on commence
par ça alors si vous les driver pas ils
vont un peu tout ça c'est compliqué
c'est vraiment la première fois et je
sais pas trop quoi faire comment leur
dire devront surveiller et c'est pas si
facile en fait d'abord passer par une
seconde générale se lève se redirige
vers la voie technologique
aujourd'hui elle est en première année
de bts management en hôtellerie
restauration
elle souhaite travailler dans les
ressources humaines au moins si je vais
donner un âge j'aurais une expérience en
plus je connais le terrain je connais et
si je veux faire de la formation
recruter des personnes eh ben je
connaîtrai je pourrais leur apprendre
des choses justes que j'aurais pas connu
si je n'avais pas eu cette expérience
avant ils apprennent à développer le
contact avec lui main pendant leur
parcours en hôtellerie donc c'est assez
courant je dirais même si ce sont des
métiers qui sont pas forcément liées à
l'hôtellerie restauration
mais elle peut se diriger sur les
grandes chaînes de restaurants par
exemple vous avez un service rh qui peut
complètement répondre à ses attentes
le lycée hôtelier saint louis compte 100
élèves cette année et pour la première
fois
il accueillera des jeunes en alternance